platform
so uh today the talk that I'm going to
take is for the 15 minutes talk is that
why we use n minus 1 as the denominator
in standard deviation calculating sample
standard deviation or variance so uh
because uh
from get go that y n minus 1 is quite it
stuck with me for quite some time why
use n minus 1. so uh if you just look at
the if you just look at the uh all the
equation for the start calculating
standard deviation as well as uh
variance uh that is where most of the
doubt comes into mind that y use n minus
1 instead of n because uh from simple
from the initial get-go that calculation
to calculate mean for the population we
use n but when you go to calculator
standard deviation we have to divide it
by the denominator has to be n minus one
uh depending uh on the sample size so
that is where the primary notion of the
Bessel correction comes into picture so
bezel correction works on so I mean what
first uh standardization and variance so
so y n minus 1 is
I mean without a long uh proofs the on
the understanding is that
to calculate sample mean uh some samples
standard deviation sample and uh sample
variance
uh the idea is that uh the population
mean and the sample mean would be quite
uh would be quite uh different depending
on the sample size sample size from a
population size so for for example if
you have sample mean X and uh population
and population mean as Mu uh
the issue would come is where the sum of
squares for sum of squares for variance
standard deviation would be higher in
case of population mean it will be lower
in case of the sample mean so the the
issue would why this this would become
why this situation would come is uh in
while taking the samples out of a
population uh all the all the samples
values all all the uh the observations
of that sample will lie closer to that
sample mean instead of the population
mean and if the uh did or the population
is quite large then that would make the
sum of squares quite large and that
that's where the bias would come in
estimating standard deviation and as
well as variance of the circle
so to fix that issue the easiest way to
do is multiply multiply or at least
multiply the actual estimator by n minus
n minus by n n so that would actually
remove the by remove the bias and given
unbiased estimator for both standard
deviation as well as uh uh variance so
the next part comes is when to use it
because
from the startup from the start of the
talk I've been talking about uh using uh
vessel correction for sample very sample
standardization and Sample variance so
in cases that as a thumb rule if uh the
sample if the sample size is quite small
compared to the population that is when
the sum of square division with the sum
of squared would be quite severe and in
those scenarios uh it can be quite
easily visible that the estimation for
the standard deviation and variance for
that sample is going to be uh quite
unbiased
so to see how actually how unbiased it
is or how much correction factor is
needed there's a simple app uh hosted a
ad scriblet so just two simple uh
screenshot here presented with low
sample size and high sample size with
the same amount of population uh with
the same population size so one can it
seem that the uh
uh the deviation between the correction
factor between the low sample size and
high sample size is quite big so I can
just show the demo if I uh present from
my screen
[Music]
um are you uh uh on a different screen
right now no no I'm on the same screen
one minute I'm just trying to share the
screen
and
yeah
yeah so yeah if you just choose the
sample size the same as the default
values you can see the uh correction
factor the correction factor uh would
deviate very much so for say with sample
size 300 the mean and the mean of the
population and mean of the uh mean of
the sample is quite uh different so if
you remove a increase the sample size
all all the way to towards thousand then
see the deviation Factor uh where the
mean of the population and mean of the
sample is quite close to each other
and uh the subsequent sample size and
subsequent sum of squared errors as well
as is reduced so in most of the cases
when the sample size is uh
sample size is lower uh
that is where the sample size is lower
that is what the Bissell correction
would come into picture
yeah I think I'm done
yeah
so thanks I can I am actually reachable
over Twitter LinkedIn and
GitHub as well so I have included the
link for the streamlit app itself as
well
so if anyone can wants to play around
with it the so I mean just to see how
much deviation how much calcium factor
is required uh I mean it's already
hosted in streamlit yeah thanks